but let me tell you something else the
most important thing
that needs to happen and this is the
final thing i want to talk about on
today's show today's main show
and that is
that i think this january 6 select
committee the riot committee whatever
you want to call it
they're now in over their heads
i do not think this committee
as it is right now
should be the lead
investigator body
into the capitol riot
i believe that it is time for merrick
garland to finally step up
and appoint a special prosecutor
to officially start
a criminal
investigation
into these events
now don't get me wrong
so far for the most part i have been
very happy with what the select
committee has done
and the reason i say they're in over
their heads
is because of the sheer scope
of what it is they're trying to do
which to be honest we don't even really
know everything they're attempting to do
yet
so you know we have to contend with that
you know they've got trump out there
they say oh we may be looking at
criminal activity here we may be looking
at criminal activity with these
individuals we got roger stone we got
steve bannon now we got members of
congress
and they can't
even if they're from opposing parties
heck almost especially if they're from
opposing parties
they now really can't
do this in a non-partisan way
because you do have lawmakers that do
have to answer these questions they
absolutely have to
that's why a special prosecutor is now
needed convene a grand jury
and essentially take it over for the
most part
because
the optics are always going to be bad
if you have a democrat-controlled
committee
subpoenaing republican members of
congress republicans are going to
weaponize that to show that oh the whole
thing is a partisan sham look they're
going after our lawmakers because this
is so ridiculous
even though there's legitimate reason to
go after them
a special prosecutor could avoid that
to a degree they're still going to claim
it's partisan witch hunt
but the bigger problem
is the longevity of this committee
this committee is not going to be able
to wrap up this investigation by the
midterms they're just not
and if they do wrap up before then
then they've cut corners in a lot of
places and it's not a complete
investigation
special prosecutor avoids that problem
because what happens when republicans
win back the house if they win back the
house
they kill the committee it's over they
disband it and what happens if members
of the committee don't win re-election
well then you're in for a real big
problem too
a special prosecutor appointed by the
attorney general avoids all of those
problems
the republicans wouldn't be able to
squash a special prosecutor we've seen
them try trust me we have
but they weren't successful with it
so that's what needs to happen now
but 100 percent of that rests upon the
shoulders of attorney general merrick
garland who has apparently just made it
clear he's not going to do anything
and for the record part of the reason
why i say that there's no way this
committee can even wrap things up by the
midterms or even by next january when
the new congress would be sworn in steve
bannon doesn't even go on trial for
contempt until july
okay you're not going to have resolution
for that um
mark meadows hasn't even been arrested
yet
so will be arrested arraigned
and then they'll set a trial which will
likely be even further out from july so
you're not going to get the cooperation
you need from these people
probably until after the election
because if they lose the cases they're
going to appeal
so this committee is doomed from the
start because of the way congress itself
is set up
but you avoid those problems
a lot of them disappear completely
if the thing is handed over to a special
prosecutor
or multiple special prosecutors
you know
appoint several there's really no limit
to how many you could appoint to handle
each different aspect of that the rally
organizers could be one focus of one
prosecutor the trump administration
could be another the members of congress
could be another and then of course all
the outside players who weren't with the
rally they weren't with the
administration or congress you know your
bannons
um uh uh
your fox news hosts
who have been texting with mark meadow
all of those other individuals could
fall into another one so there you go
but anyway listen we're out of time for
today's show i'm fair and cousins find
me on social media at fahren balanced
we've got a wonderful bonus show coming
up for you today including roger stone
flip-flopping on what actually caused
the capital riot i'm faring cousins in
for david pakman thanks for tuning in